he is one of the greatest coaches any
sport has seen over the last 20 years
kansas city chiefs head coach andy reed
joining us here on set at the league
meetings in arizona coach great to see
you as always great to be here yes so uh
look we love your team we love your
quarterback we but it's just
unbelievable when did when did you know
that patrick mahomes was going to become
the guy that he became this past year
yeah so brett veach hit me early early
on him when he was still attacked there
and
and then chris helped with his tweet
[Laughter]
so uh between those two i i felt pretty
confident that that we had a player uh
that was good then i had a chance to
look at him and
and talk to him and
all you need is five minutes with a kid
you know what he's about right
he's solid um
and then he comes on board and he he
does everything you ask him to do
he doesn't try to trump alex smith right
and that could be sticky you know that
how that goes right um alex was
phenomenal with him uh i mean he owes
alex the world there just on
on how
both of them handle each other but the
things that alex taught him about being
a pro
and then he put that into use we had a
chance kind of a dress rehearsal uh when
he played denver not knowing that
yeah not knowing that we were
going to lose alex the next year
but
he steps in and does a heck of a job for
us against their defense i mean it
wasn't like they weren't playing their
guys right
and and um
and so we had a chance to see him he did
the same things he did in practice so
those no look things little you know all
that stuff uh we didn't see a left-hand
throw in that game but he came back and
did one uh against he throws better
left-hander than he does
i don't know about that
thanks coach yeah thanks he likes to
brag on him that's all right that's all
right so anyways you know we saw it in
that game and we saw it every day in
practice and it felt pretty comfortable
uh with the move there is there is there
one specific play early on or in
practice where you just went like like i
knew this guy is good but holy cow like
that was unreal i mean is there a moment
like that yeah he did he did one of
those no-look jobs in practice early
yeah and justin houston went this way
and the ball went that way and justin
looked over and you could always tell
with players right when players go man
this dude's a real deal uh
you know you're
pretty sure that's uh that's the case
um so justin really you know he went
listen this guy's unbelievable right i
mean that thing he just did right there
you just don't see but
i keep going back to the 2017 season you
guys started off so strong and then it
kind of sputtered in the middle and the
offense was kind of sputtering in
hindsight how how tempting was it for
you to say well you know we got this kid
we know what he can do maybe this is the
spark we need alex will be fine with it
maybe on a short-term basis did you
think about that at all that season
because now we see what he can do it's
kind of like hey maybe he could have
done it that year too yeah i didn't uh
listen i i i benched myself is what i
did and uh i have a ton of respect for
alex and
and the things that he does and we just
needed a little change up in there just
something to change and i
i'm normally going to look at myself
first before i go to the go to the
player and
and so i sat down and let and just gave
him a little different flavor a little
different role and and he took off with
it and and uh did a heck of a job and so
now
alex is a class act and he's a good
football player you saw that in
washington i mean
for jay he was doing a heck of a job
there and
before he had this stinking injury man
you know we were all pulling for him we
watched every one of his game we were
excited to watch him play
that's how much love we had for him in
the building there
what is you know mahomes seems so calm
and cool and you have a great way about
you too you sit him on the bench
what is the things he needs to improve
what are the things you get mad at him
for you know every now and then as a as
a coach yeah so the second year you know
the these great minds defensive minds of
the nfl have a chance to
go back and look at him and study them
right
well at the same time he has an
opportunity to study himself and
and so those cut-ups that we put
together and gone through as a staff and
critiqued and
changed here or there i mean that's
going to be so beneficial to him the
second year he'll handle it the right
way sometimes guys get complacent that's
not his nature he'll keep driving it he
wants to be a great player and and uh
and that's how he's wired so uh but
that'll be the challenge uh this
offseason and he's got he's got little
things i mean they're things sure sure
you're always working on feet i mean
that's a continuous thing that's like
being a farmer right the work's never
done there man you're gonna keep working
that ultimate platform to throw from and
and so uh no matter who's chasing or or
how you have to move off a three
technique whatever it might be so he
he's
he's great with all that stuff at
working it and he'll continue to do that
you know you've got the play design
you've got the things you want your
quarterback to do at what point do you
accept you know what
just just let him do whatever it is that
he does because he's getting results
even if i look at it on film and say
that's probably not the best way to make
it happen he still makes it happen yeah
sure i learned that with brett nothing
was
pretty but when the ball came out it was
uh it was a beautiful thing so
um and his consistency was the chin to
the shoulder on his follow through and
he and johnny united were kind of the
two guys that that really had that um
but brett was all over the place with
his feet and
arm ankles and everything else but when
the follow-through came it was kind of
the same a little bit like arnold palmer
jack nicholas you know
tiger woods you look at those guys the
back swings different but when the club
head hits it it's perfect it's perfect
you know it kind of gets to the same
point so
uh with the quarterback i don't care
about all that stuff i mean i don't care
how it looks i'm not trying to change
all i'm not trying to change his game
that's why we brought him there we saw
what we saw at texas tech the same thing
you guys saw so
um
you leave that alone
and then if there's a problem
you you get enough reps with them if
there's a problem let's fix that problem
let's go in and kind of sort it out and
see what we can do with a couple extra
reps and maybe maybe a tweak here or
there i you brought up brett i was gonna
go there because i mean how much was
your experience seeing brett and that
special arm you know maybe uh give you
an eye for that kind of specialness and
what other similarities are you know
just the things that they're liking well
listen you know i've been blessed with
great quarterback i mean donovan was
amazing yeah the same deal so he was a
guy that moved around and they all put
their own personalities to it
that's a fun part of it so
um he's he's similar to brett that he
does some crazy things i mean i've seen
brett throw
left-handed i've seen him do no look
throws i mean we've seen it all right
from over the years so
he does all that uh same stuff it just
comes natural to them yeah i mean it's
like they're playing in the backyard and
and uh that's what makes them unique and
they can they have great vision
their peripheral vision's phenomenal
and and their timing just that sense of
uh where's that junction point gonna be
and what can i get away with with it
uh there's just that innate thing that
they've got he doesn't seem as a handful
as brett was on the sidelines when i
watch all nfl films things and you know
you and mike trying to uh kind of reign
in brett so i guess it's a little easier
from that aspect with that says great
remember when he picked up mr miyagi
i mean he saw ever he didn't miss
anything right he saw everybody uh
everywhere um and they're they're all
there everybody's different right we're
all different uh personalities and
and uh and that's the way
brett was and donovan donovan was the
funniest guy out there still had the
great vision he would kill people i mean
when he was mic'd up it was it was a it
was like having a comedian miked up so
anyways
they're all different right right we're
all on the same page about patrick
mahomes but only two of us are on the
same page about one very important issue
we had to watch patrick mahomes on the
sidelines in overtime of the afc
championship game the chiefs are at the
front of the charge to ensure that
there'll be a position or a possession
rather for the team that kicks off he's
against it i'm in favor of it why did
you guys decide to put that forward yeah
so uh well listen i i would love to he's
trying to start something
when you have a great quarterback uh
you'd love to have that that ball
yeah that opportunity so and there are
ways around it i think the fans would
love it you get in those playoffs and
and uh you can't tell me that if that
patriot game went on a little bit longer
that people would turn it off i mean
everybody would be you're right yeah
it's not we were we were all in i guess
what i worry about is okay
you know brady scores you guys and my
home scores and now brady scores again
and they're gonna go oh well it's not
fair my homes didn't get to go a second
yeah that's where i i think yeah well
that's possibility but i've gone for two
you're going for two and one in the game
i mean there are their options um what
about and i don't want to i want to talk
about this player tyree kill i know he's
got some off the field things he's got
to handle but i want to talk about him
on the field
is he the fastest player you've ever had
on the football team yeah well i was
blessed also coach the shop i know so
that's awesome
yeah those two can giddy up and go no i
mean i'm i think you're splitting hairs
yeah okay they're both very very fast um
i like uh testing their speed i mean i
don't mind like uh let's let's let's go
yeah i know take five hitch and throw it
as far as you can throw it let's see
let's see if we can keep it uh
you know completed so um that there
both guys are fast yeah you know we saw
what the patriots did to stop tyree
kelly slow him down in the afc
championship game and you looted this
earlier defenses are going to have seven
months to figure out how to crack the
code on this chief's offense how
aggressively will you
self-scout yourself as chris would say
and try to stay ahead of that curve
going into 2019. absolutely i mean you
know that's the fun part about it i mean
you keep building it and it's uh
you know you get done it's a beautiful
monster so you just keep going and going
and it grows like i said before this
part's like being a farmer you're
there's there's always work to be done
right and uh and that's a fun part of it
that's part of the coaches love and
players if you're into it and you're
bringing them good stuff
they want to chew it up and digest it
and then go
perform it
uh at a high level and so uh
if you're blessed to have one of those
guys that feels that way
leading the pack everybody's gonna
follow right so he he's wired that way
where
uh
he
you know give me something give me
something good yeah yeah and they're
great players i've been around some hall
of fame players the great ones want that
they want you to give them
one more thing that even makes them
greater
and that's what makes coaching so much
fun yeah well coach we're rooting for
you in 2019 and beyond we love the
results we're going to get well
in your closet when you open up your
closet do you have a lot of these all
you do you just give tommy bahama give
him a couple plugs and they'll have this
right on there i'll put it it'll just
like it'll just appear tommy yeah tommy
tommy bahama nbcsn yeah it's a very
colorful logo you put it on there and
off we go no that's what i'm talking
about all right coach hey thanks so much
for your time congratulations we love
your team we love you we love your
quarterback and we wish you the best in
2019. i appreciate it guys thank you yup
all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports